and
a sport
leave
I'll do the talking
passport
what's happening Shh haha the area but
never but now but now Makai what about
here though bard major you know my range
right Anika huh hard major vicek
Oviedo today we're lucky what's going on
little job big up good you make up hello
Nova Johnny take it slow look
leaving at all
I don't know
I distinctly remember saying stop the
bus
yes stop the bus up to the bus
I'm very particular with my words
stop shoot stop
shoot do those words sound say letter go
out of control I'm sorry I didn't hear
what you say it got out of control not
out of control hate when things get out
of control
oh well okay Japanese couldn't [ __ ]
doughnuts and I got blood on my [ __ ]
shells
at least there's a silver lining we
didn't completely [ __ ] it up yeah boy
I'd recognize those eyes anywhere I'm so
sorry about this
this was supposed to be well not there
sir we have a party waiting for you but
I don't think I know your name who is
this hmm
is this your plus-one but strong silent
type I like it I am terribly embarrassed
about all this this was supposed to be
very simple but you know if you know two
monkeys they just throw their [ __ ] at
each other you know would you hold it
for just a moment I want to get a little
sure right into the camera there we are
awesome
don't worry about a thing my boy this
will soon be behind us it'll be off on a
grand adventure because I have cleared
my calendar for you you and I are gonna
- shut up